[Applause]
alright what's up guys we just finished
a meeting and the meeting was for our
vlogging course TIFF and I are gonna be
teachers instructors now that's so weird
I never thought I would be teaching
anyone anything in my life
but yeah it's not like with the camera
life with the camera and it's very
exciting because as of right now the
moment this video comes out our vlogging
course is available yay so exciting
there's a first time ever we've ever
released something of our own that's
true Oh proud and we're so excited for
you guys to see it
we also want to give a big big big thank
you to everyone of you that have signed
up to our mailing list there's quite a
few of you guys you know thank you so
much for signing up you guys will be
getting a very special email if you
haven't seen it already go check out
your emails yeah you guys were curious
like what are you guys talking about so
this is a vlogging course that we've
created because a few years ago Casey
was trying to teach me how to edit our
videos cuz he's just had so much on his
plate that it would just be easier if I
helped too so when he was teaching me
how to do these rough cuts we realized
like hey you know what people are always
commenting that they want to know more
about the way casey edits and like his
techniques like for editing tips and
stuff like that and we're like wait
you're telling me all that like we
should just create some things for you
guys since you guys have been really
curious over the years it's something
that we've been working on for about two
years
and it's been a minute because we've
really wanted to get this right to make
sure that by the time you guys get it
it's the best condition it could
possibly be in
yeah the first iteration of this project
we had it was really vague the
information and so were like hold on a
second this is not right so we had to
like take our time to really figure out
what it is that we're trying to do with
this logging course in case II was
trying to think of it from like where he
stands I know all this right he's like
oh yeah this is basic stuff so then I'll
come in and be like wait but how do you
do that and then how do you get there
I'm like oh right right so yeah like
that's by step we don't like continue to
put more info into this and make it
worth it for you guys to because we also
want you guys to be happy oh we also
have a trailer for you we're gonna play
the trailer for you right now actually
my very first experience with being in
front of a camera so you demonstrate
real quick what you did have you seen
this footage before no one has ever seen
that footage cause it's embarrassing hi
my name is Tiffany and my name is Casey
and together we have a youtube channel
called Tiffin case where we showcase our
married live with my son
today we're gonna be talking about how
we blog it's kind of like going on a
date with yourself
cameras they all come in different
shapes sizes quality and prices kind of
funny because I see a lot of people
asking us what kind of cameras we do
editing can be one of the most daunting
parts about making a vlog but today
we're gonna break it down or we're all
gonna learn how to edit there's the
filming part and there's the editing
process where you're gonna be seeing
yourself over and over again and you're
gonna be thinking every step of the way
I hate it I hate it I hate it I hate it
oh the biggest thing for me why me
like oh my gosh I sound like that back
during my childhood my dad started
vlogging without even realizing it that
you saw me holding a camera and shooting
movie everywhere we go
yeah but he didn't have the editing
software back then so he wasn't able to
actually edit the videos the way you
wanted it to now I want to share what I
know about making videos for people like
him so the reason why I wanted to vlog
was because I haven't son and I missed
out on a lot of his infancy and a lot of
those early stages I didn't really get
to capture and now that he's getting
older I need to capture how he is right
now and I want to be able to show him
that in the future my favorite things to
record are actually these little candid
moments of Tiff's and Isaac and they
least expect that I'm always trying to
get these like small slivers of gold you
might forget what you say you might
forget what you did but how you feel
it's gonna be the one thing you're gonna
hold on to for the rest of your life
it's the part that you never remember
the best you don't remember some of the
stuff that happened when you're a child
but you remember how you felt about
certain things and that's exactly what
you really tap
so don't be scared to get out there and
start recording and start clogging start
capturing those memories because life is
too short so you don't want to miss it
join us in our life of the camera and
grab hold of those precious moment
[Music]
alright guys so what'd you think
are you excited to capture your memories
with us and learn how to create
beautiful videos the way Casey does them
because I have no credit in that that's
all Casey no it's you too
I mean I'm in front of the camera behind
my head in my way I would never I would
never talk to the camera I don't
particularly like talking to the right
so I mean yeah but I'm talking about how
to make think the video so beautiful you
know like you could take any footage and
make it look great so since we've just
launched this we really want to give
back to you guys who have been
supporting us through all these years
and so we just want to give you guys
like you know a little discount off of
the vlogging course so make sure to go
to the website to check out the discount
and just FYI on January 5th exactly as
the clock strikes midnight here in the
Pacific Standard Time bad discount will
no longer be available so if you guys
are interested in this vlogging course
make sure to check out the website and
then if you guys are kind of hesitant
and signing up you're like hold on I
don't really understand what's happening
here
I don't know I'm gonna I'm getting
myself into we also have a three-part
mini course available that's completely
free so you guys to get a little sneak
peek into what we have in the full
course check out the mini course and you
can get that by signing up to the
mailing list as well so if you have been
thinking about blogging your life your
memories your experiences but you have
been weighed too intimidated to start
because vlogging can be very
intimidating especially if you don't
even know where
again then make sure to head over to
life with the camera comm and we will
guide you step by step and I think it's
kind of cool if you start now because
you can capture 2019 and then you can
kind of look back on it and be like cool
I did all those things in that one year
so I challenge you to vlog your life for
one year new year's resolutions
yeah and beyond that goes for you
because I think it will help you guys a
lot especially if you suffer from like
low self-esteem or little confidence and
all that stuff like vlogging has really
helped me personally just get out of my
own bubble just get out of my own shell
and I think it's pretty helpful it's
like it's like writing to diary but not
it's better than reading it I feel like
it's really helped me over these last
few years vlogging and sharing my life
with you guys and capturing our lives
together and just being able to look
back on the videos cuz very frequently I
look back and watch our vlogs and it's
just always so cool because the way
Casey edit these videos or just I end up
telling him all the time I'm like man
that's so crazy how you're able to
capture the emotion I felt in that
moment and like really emphasize it
through the editing cuz it's always so
fun watching your videos it never feels
boring here
it doesn't feel mundane you know so we
hope that you guys get the most out of
this vlogging chorionic you yeah and so
you guys can also have your memories be
captured and like you know like just
bottle up those emotions you fill in
that moment so yeah check it out
alright so for the rest of the day we
have planned to have Isaac open up his
Christmas presents early so this Sunday
we leave to Hong Kong with the entire
Chan clan we're gonna be going to Hong
Kong but um Isaac's dad wanted to give
him this Christmas presents before he
leaves so his dad is heading over right
now I have to rush and wrap Isaac's
presents because I've just been so busy
and caught up with life with the camera
that I totally forgot to wrap his
presents so I got to do that and the
reason why we're doing it now and not
later is because we want Isaac to be
able to use his Christmas presents on
the trip
and it's kind of cool time we sort of
team up with Isaac's dad for his
Christmas presents like we got the main
thing and then
you got the things that go with it I'm
not trying I'm trying not to tell you
guys until you it so you guys can
experience it yeah oh I think spring
[Music]
and what's cool about seeing UVM mom and
do all these mom things like wrapping
presents what is that I could imagine
how my mom was with me and like I was
like oh the behind the scenes of what my
mom did 30 years ago no no I have Oh
every time every time I do see you Grant
presents I think about like what my mom
would had done for me I'm like my mom
probably had her wrapped presents like
five minutes before she had to pick me
up too maybe maybe I hurt him but more
or less the idea that right there's like
a huge like you know pressure to to
create the the excitement and illusion
for your kids and and no matter how old
it yet you still want to provide that
right she told you to wrap your own
presence but like the only time that I
would get a present that was a surprise
was a note get it from a family member
present from my mom and my stepdad like
I always knew about them I see that's a
hilarious and sad so sad
at the same time every time I talk about
my past my childhood no matter what it's
always like a sad thing I don't mean to
but that's just my experience in life
they always make fun of me for that too
my whooping Island a pro our every
presents though because I spent my
childhood wrapping presents
oh nice that's true I can't wrap
presents say there's if you want
wrinkles and increases and the most
craziest like most like blatantly like
why is there a crease there places of
the wrapping there you asked me to do it
you know I'm kind of glad you don't
anymore
like so Kayson I have agreed that we are
no longer giving each other presents
we're just gonna plan trips and
experiences together
so yeah Casey is not getting anything
from me for Christmas and I don't expect
to get anything for Christmas from you
because we already agreed that we're not
getting give each other presents
oh but except mutually wait for the next
video it's my birthday slash our
Christmas present I'm so excited please
see that video I wish I could show you
now but you guys have to wait for the
next video
hey my boy look at you handsome with
your Santa hat I mean Santa hat Santa
suit I'm out of breath because I was
rushing do you I don't know why it's
Christmastime christmas came early for
you dude wait lee yep you're wearing the
suit so your dad is here yeah go say hi
hey Dad so your dad's here because we're
giving you your Christmas presents early
yeah you're excited
yeah where's our tight oh thank you
oh you pick it up does either say that
you look so cute hey all right dude time
to open presents so you didn't give me a
hug by the way okay baby I want you to
open from the biggest present and then
the second biggest and then the bag and
then the two little one that's the order
okay
Christmas cut presents come with
instructions yep it's open the biggest
one first I can't rip it yeah destroy it
man what is it I got you a Lego super
heroes
Lego thing the Marvel Avengers you've
been dying yeah tell me you bought this
for like months he's been wanting this
you like it you like it you like it
thank you
now second biggest one
[Music]
[Applause]
never show this much expression alright
baby now in this super mario party and
then mario kart to the final one alright
so now is gonna head over for the
weekend and you and i Casey have a
dinner date important geo thangka take
it just woke up from a nap but with the
bed hmm
we're gonna have dinner so Isaac went to
his dad's now for the weekend and we're
gonna have some delicious Tokyo fried
chicken cuz we mentally off his vegan
diet which we haven't even talked I
never talked about okay so I've been a
vegan on and off the in vegetarian
pescetarian for the past four weeks of
last month just to test my my der bilt
my skin's durability two different foods
because of eczema quite successful with
the vegan stuff cleared up a lot of my
on the life over here I was successful
with the vegan stuff because I think I'm
allergic to animal product or something
like meat or something and every time I
eat meat I was like getting a little
rashes here and there because in the
moment I cleared up my skin my diet went
all plant and stuff like it all went
away so now I need to figure out a way
to be completely happy eating plan
food out of that or I gotta figure out a
way to incorporate stuff I like to eat
like animals and and be happy with my
skin somehow I don't know yet so
scientific anyways we're breaking that
diet today though we are going for some
fried chicken I'll do mommy look okay I
think I'm not your puppet yeah
I'm not your monkey you done just done
what did this Mac you like what is that
like I cared for my earrings really I'm
just kidding I'm just kidding
take it the smacker
[Applause]
look everyone needs to return there was
that Diplodocus is it like Ronnie smiles
like that everything said no he's in the
know that's hilarious
cuter you just made the cutest baby ever
this is the needs of Judah and
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
fried chicken family here I'm super
excited that's Frank my vegan diet I
feel like I'm about to have the runs
tonight though how do you describe the
mac and cheese here
[Music]
[Applause]
new word mac and cheese I'm so excited
for this chicken and every move out and
also heady about the whole vegan thing
and explain what the Tokyo Fried Chicken
ISM this is really bomb project is fiery
and they do it a very successful fusion
of Southern Fried Chicken and Japanese
fraction
not only is the fried chicken amazing
all the side dishes are successfully
fused together between southern and what
are you doing can i such places as
though you're so cute because that guy
was on my phone and he kind of like taps
me his little paw he's like hey hey mom
mom
and then so I I like look at him and he
like just settled in here in this little
nook
now he's getting over it because he's
like hyung getting too much attention
for this
he likes private time between us yeah so
what's that he's so cute
you know when Isaac's gone here you ends
up being my Isaac fill in your
replacement not replacing it that sounds
weird that's why I said like a fill-in
you know hmm
I liked seeing Isaac open his presents
and it was really cool having his dad
here too because I don't know it's kind
of cool saying my son I'd be able to
experience having such strong parents
you know like the parent bonding like
the co-parenting that we have because I
definitely wish I had that in my life
and seeing my son how that it's just
like oh just like makes me so happy and
I could tell on him to like within
himself - every time the three of us are
together like a little part of him
inside it's like he's happy yeah it's
really nice because it was tough like
like my previous relationship after his
dad like they didn't get along at all
you're the previous guy and Isaac's dad
didn't get along yeah cuz you could feel
the tension in the room and like you
just weighed heavy on like both me and
Isaac cuz it psychologist sucks like you
know there
just they can't have a relationship it
was really nice saying how you two have
a relationship like every time he comes
over like they end up talking for like a
like an awkward yeah I think they're
always talking and like forever it's
like they're best friends it's funny but
yeah so it's really cool saying how you
guys get along and even just today like
after opening the whole presence and
everything he ended up talking to you
for like a whole nother area not telling
you how he respects you and how he sees
I he he calls you like a real man
because you take on the job of being
there for his son and like it was just
really sweet hearing that conversation
and he's I can you know I'm just really
happy that Tiff's happy because you know
like you you've been able to fill in for
where he lacked and things like that
like it was just really like from the
heart goes really nice Karma's very
honest how do you feel about the whole
situation neck save it he was even
saying like you know you're part of his
family yeah like you he like he knows
that because you love Isaac like pretty
much love him the way he said that to I
was like oh that's so sweet that's so
deep it is really deep yeah deep dude
yeah yeah I don't know I feel I feel
really like honored I guess to be
referred to in such a way where you know
like no one's ever come up to me said
you're a real like pink of my stuff like
that either you know it's just I'm just
trying my best to do what's right that
makes sense to me
you know I feel like everyone who tries
to do that you know it's for someone to
acknowledge that what you're trying to
do is right and is what a real man is
and like is honest and like genuine like
I'm like
it's that's a really cool compliment so
yeah yeah and I was telling his dad -
I'm like man and we hit the double
whammy because I because your parents
love Isaac like if he was their own
flesh and blood
like that's how lucky we got with you
guys and obviously it's like it just
shows how amazing your parents are
because they were able to raise such a
great man to the point where you can
also pass down carry on there get a lot
of my sensibilities from my parents and
so kudos to them I know they're amazing
I love them so much I can't wait to see
them and we're gonna be able to see them
we're about to see them in two days I
gotta start packing
I have not packed and we're leaving and
you have so much editing to do because
you're editing this video tonight
overnight yeah so we can release it by
tomorrow so yeah so that's that you
gotta go edit this yes well I figure out
if I want to pack tonight or I'll do it
tomorrow
like too late a couple of hours later I
want to come up here and viously
I'll try to Co for you if I may you're
editing this I can't help but notice
that in the trailer of the video course
the shirt I'm wearing is also the shirt
I'm wearing shirt I was like oh yeah oh
and I'm wearing white - oh yeah I
honestly miss my blue hair I kind of
want to get it back again but then Steve
always makes fun of people with both
hair sure you get my blue hair back guys
[Music]